Movies are like games of Jenga: if just one
piece is out of place, the entire thing collapses,
no matter how well built the rest of it is.
Even movies that otherwise were great have
been ruined by a bad decision.
Here's a look at movies that were destroyed
by just one scene...
The Dark Knight Rises
The Dark Knight Rises was full of little head-scratching
moments, such as "If the villain's plan is
to blow up Gotham after holding it hostage,
why does he wait all those months to do it?"
Most of these you can just let slide, but
the reveal of Joseph Gordon-Levitt's real
identity?
That's...that's just too much.
"Nothing here."
"Try my legal name."
"You should use your full name, I like that
name—Robin."
You know, Robin!
Of course, in the comics, Robin's real name
is Dick.
Or Jason.
Or Tim.
Or Damien.
Or even Stephanie.
But apparently any of those names would have
been too subtle for movie audiences, so they
hit you over the head instead.
It's like revealing this dude's name is "John
Aquaman" or something.
Interstellar
At the climax of Christopher Nolan's sci-fi
epic Interstellar, Matthew McConaughey's pilot
character falls into a black hole and lands
inside a far-flung future device that lets
him send cryptic messages to his daughter
in the past.
Or in other words, he has to use some hippy-dippy
Morse Code machine to save the future using
— that's right — the power of love.
"No, no, no, no, Murph!! MURPH!!!! No! No!"
Really?
Love?
That's the secret to unlocking the mysteries
of the time-space continuum?
"Great Scott!"
Why didn't they just end the movie with this
song, then?
"...but it might just save your life, that's
the power of love."
Prometheus
There was a minute there where it looked like
Ridley Scott's Prometheus was going to be
one of the coolest movies ever made.
But what it turned out to be was a slow exercise
in cluelessness.
Plenty of fans either love it or hate it,
but it's hard to argue about that one, sequence
where the characters have to avoid being crushed
by a rolling spaceship.
It looks tense, exciting, thrilling even — right
up until you ask yourself: why didn't they
just move to the side instead of trying to
outrun it?
In fact, the main character lives simply by
rolling three feet.
Now if only she had told her buddy to do the
same thing, maybe we wouldn't have left the
theater feeling profoundly stupider.
12 Years a Slave
Throughout the majority of 12 Years a Slave,
the story of Solomon Northup, a free man who
was kidnapped and forced into slavery, is
artfully told through brutal visuals and compelling
performances.
Then Brad Pitt shows up.
And he speaks, using whatever that accent
this was supposed to be, with his Brad Pitt
acting and his Brad Pitt face:
"Freedom is everything.
The fact that I can even walk out here tomorrow
brings me great pleasure."
Uh...start walking, Brad.
That would give us great pleasure.
Let the Right One In
Let the Right One In is a rare kind of horror
movie, a haunting character study with few
loud moments or overt scares.
It is, simply put, an excellent, creepy flick.
But it does have one massive, unintentional
belly laugh moment that kinda ruins it...
(cats roaring and hissing)
Here's a free tip to any future horror movie
directors.
If you want to keep your audience terrified,
and on the edge of their seats, just skip
the evil attack kittens.
Kittens can't really pull off the evil thing,
y'know?
They're just too damn cute!
"I'm going to kill you!"
Star Wars: Special Edition
In 1997, fans were excited at the chance to
see the remastered Star Wars trilogy on the
big screen.
And then...this happened.
"I bet you have."
In an instant, people realized George Lucas
hadn't improved the series with the Special
Editions.
He'd ruined it.
The collective scream of distraught fans is
still reverberating around the universe.
"I felt a great disturbance in the Force.
As if millions of voices suddenly cried out
in terror and were suddenly silenced."
Well...maybe not exactly "silenced."
Return of the Jedi: Special Edition
Now, you can almost understand the thought
process behind having Greedo shoot first.
But for every revision Lucas has explained,
there are at least three others made to the
trilogy are just random and bizarre.
And none of them are more random, or more
bizarre, than the insanely stupid "Jedi Rocks"
dance number in the middle of Return of the
Jedi.
Prepare yourselves:
"I have a very bad feeling about this."
(horrible music playing)
"No!"
"Nooooo!
No!"
"No, no, no!"
"I don't really have a lot of awards, to be
very honest with you."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!